but uh yeah we've uh made it to los
angeles um and we've somehow found like
been able to build a studio despite a
lot of issues oh that's we're gonna get
into that very quickly um i'm sure the
the rounds have already
been made of the actual situation yeah
the rounds have already been there
people online if you've been on reddit
maybe you're aware of this uh if not
which i'm like a big portion of the
audience isn't uh
yeah so
our baggage
containing melin said it was thirty
thousand dollars worth of equipment it's
actually i think closer to fifty
thousand yeah
yeah closer to fifty thousand worth
dollars worth of filming equipment all
our mics all our cameras uh were lost on
the way here
and uh at this point at this moment we
still don't know where they are yeah
yeah so we had to like scramble to get
all of this equipment so that we can
actually film some episodes and you know
especially because we're going to get
guests on eventually as well yeah from
next episode yeah so uh
it's just stressful as [ __ ] this was not
the start that we wanted i'm so thankful
that we scheduled in like two three free
days of just like no guests no filming
anything yeah uh because if we if we
thought that we were gonna hit the
ground running we would have been [ __ ]
like i guess literally arrives and it's
like so where's the set like uh
about that yeah it doesn't exist yet do
you want to explain your process of
going to okay
so i was in charge of bringing all of
the equipment uh to america because
these boys flew a bit early uh so i get
to heathrow airport terminal 2
and i already like already alarm bells
were ringing because i get there and i
want to check in
and i can't check in and i hear one of
the operators say oh no we can't check
anyone in right now because there is a
queue downstairs of about 200 bags and
no one can check in right now so i'm
like
that's uh that's that's that's pretty
bad that's that's that's a little that's
like that's like a bad omen right there
yeah that's worrying yeah so i arrived
you know an hour no two hours before my
flights as like that's what they
recommend so i have to wait an hour just
to check in my bags just checking my
bags right
uh and that's true for like pretty much
everyone on the plane so i check in my
bags an hour before our flight and then
i check in my normal bags and then i
have we have two massive pelican cases
containing all of our filming equipment
and um they look at that and they're
like
we can't check that in here you're gonna
have to go to the oversized luggage like
section i'm like i'm like oh no oh no
this is this is this is this is scary
i'm like my spidey senses were tingling
yeah you know i was like something is
going to go wrong
so i bring over the two pelican cases
over to the oversized luggage place and
uh so there's an operator there and you
could tell like this operator she was
[ __ ] done he did he he does not give
he's dealing with this for a few days
yeah yeah yeah he does not give a [ __ ]
at all right and then he looks at the
cases and he's like all right just just
put them put them on there put them on
the conveyor belt and i'll get it
through the system and then he i put it
on the conveyor belt he presses a button
to open a shutter to get it through the
airport the shutter doesn't open
and here he presses again doesn't open
and i'm like okay uh there's something
weird going on here is this a mouth
like malfunction or something and he
just he sits there he sits down and he
sits there for five minutes doing
nothing doing like like doing nothing
right he just sits there for five
minutes and i'd like to like pretend to
work yeah he just doesn't even pretend
to work he just sits down and like plays
on his phone and then like while i'm
waiting a queue starts to form behind me
first it's like one person then it's two
people then it's three people and like
it it really starts to build up right
and so after about 10 minutes of just
sitting down doing nothing the guy just
like tries to press it again
doesn't work and then he finally he like
phones he like tries to phone somebody
he tries to do something about it
um and so he phones the operator in
charge of whoever is in charge of the
baggage uh and uh he says oh the shutter
won't open and then they say uh yeah
we're not letting any bags in right now
because we are just completely full like
we cannot take any more bags into our
system right and so i was waiting for
about like 20 minutes
uh and so you know i was waiting in this
queue for about 20 minutes before he
presses the button and the shutter
finally opens and like right the [ __ ]
bags finally went through and i remember
by the time my bags went through it was
half an hour before my flight
and like
i like i remember thinking finally the
shutters open bag goes through
and then the shutter closed and there
was just this moment
of
i'm never going to see them again
[Music]
like i had i had a feeling i had a
feeling self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
yeah you had had like a [ __ ] vision
it closed and i'm just like okay i was
like i have a bad feeling about this
like
[ __ ] obi-wan and um i remember
texting the group being like uh guys not
to be alarmed but i'm pretty sure
there's there's a good chance that maybe
we won't get to see our equipment but i
was like hoping out of hope
yeah
and so you know i check in we go through
uh so we i flew air lingus so the
airlingus flight goes from dublin so it
goes from heathrow to dublin and then
dublin to america lax
and so uh the
flight from dublin that's the flight
from heathrow to dublin was actually on
time which i think that's the reason our
bags didn't get delivered because it was
on time and we woke up the next day and
we found out that there's there's an
image on screen with all of the bags
that are like stuck in heathrow terminal
two now it's like a [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] sea of bags right our bag is
somewhere in there at this point
um but then after that
uh i check into my second flight to go
to america
and we all check in i'm sitting in my
seat and then it's you know you know
where you have some of those flights
where for some reason the plane just
doesn't move yeah right right so i we
were sitting there for like a full-on
hour right so like we were sitting there
for a full an hour trying to figure out
what's going on you know are we actually
gonna take off
and then after an hour like the operator
comes in and we and was like guys i know
you've been waiting a while uh that's
because there's been a massive queue on
the runway right now uh so we're gonna
be a bit delayed and i'm gonna be real
with you uh it's looking like that we're
gonna be sitting here for another two
hours
so
like
like you know when like bad news gets
announced and you just feel the air just
drop yeah yeah like like there was like
that [ __ ] groan noise that just
distributed throughout the entire
[ __ ] plane right and everyone's just
like what the [ __ ]
so
we all start getting out our phones and
everything like that and uh you know i
i you know i was thankful because i got
to catch up with [ __ ] spy family you
know
that's what i did with my extra two
hours on the tarmac but after worse
but like after being delayed for three
hours on the tarmac finally i get to go
to lax
[ __ ] [ __ ] brilliant i finally i
finally get to go my flight to america
the flight itself was very very pleasant
you know um you know we had some very
good uh
what they called air stewardesses there
you know service yeah service we had
very good service uh the flight itself
was great but then
the nightmare continued when i landed in
lax right and
that's just any landing in l.a yeah yeah
yeah the nightmare continues yeah and so
i get i i get down and i thought that i
had saved time because if you fly from
dublin to america we have pre-clearance
so we don't like if you fly from dublin
you don't actually need to go through
immigration in america that's very
[ __ ] good yeah you can go through
immigration in dublin yeah so it's
treated as a domestic flight so i'm like
great i could just pick my bags and get
the [ __ ] out of there yeah uh and so i
walk for what feels like 20 minutes to
get to my baggage collection right yeah
we all had to do that yeah yeah yeah
yeah and
by the time i get there our bags aren't
even on the carousel because they are so
busy that they are still
like the people from the previous
flights are still getting their bags
from this carousel because there's only
one carousel in the domestic terminal
yeah so we that we like people from
hawaii were still like which was the
flight before we're still waiting for
their bags to come out so we couldn't
get our bags before the passengers from
hawaii could completely get their bags
out so i was waiting for about an hour
before we even got any of
any bags from our flights to come out
and then
after our after our bags after their
bags finished getting uh collected
finally our bags come out and it's it's
like it's like a drip feed i don't know
how
i don't know how it was such a slow drip
feed were like were there like [ __ ]
cycling it over like one bag at a time
because i was like dragging it over the
whole
journey
yeah so
so
it was coming out like [ __ ] five bags
at a time like it's so by the time
by the time
like i got some of my bags out i had to
wait another like 20 30 minutes and then
of course i was waiting for my equipment
bags and then i wait i waited a little
longer i waited a little longer and they
were like uh so thank you ladies and
gentlemen uh the air lingus bag flights
uh at the airlingus flight bags are now
finished uh so if you have any bags to
collect uh we've collected it in a
corner
and i was just like [ __ ] i do not i did
not see
the bags i had you know i would rather
have lost my clothes than lose the 50
000 yeah of of equipment so i go to this
corner and there's a line of about 30
people being like where the [ __ ] is my
bag
and and so
after that i have to queue again with
the with these 20 30 people all trying
to like wave their [ __ ] tickets to
like uh it's like pick a form up and
like
it was like my first reminder about
you know what i can experience here in
terms of customer service because i'm
used to japanese customer service
yeah yeah i i'm very blessed with
japanese customer service where they
felt like you know they will do anything
they can to help you or at least they
they were like at least pretend to give
you [ __ ] yeah right yeah like at lax
like i've had two instances now where
there is not even any pretending to give
a [ __ ] about the customer at all like
like if anything i felt guilty for
having to trouble them for an issue with
the [ __ ] airport you know so like i
guess so like i had to like [ __ ]
fight my way through until i give them
the ticket and this guy punching my
numbers in uh to this lost and found
form just could not give a [ __ ] he could
he like
he like he didn't give a [ __ ] so much
that it ended up we found out later that
he'd punched in the wrong numbers to
this form
and so it was like this
it was this experience of everything
that could go wrong with a flight did go
wrong and it turned a already long
travel time from england to america and
added around five to six hours on top of
that as well
so sorry yeah yeah
she's staying here yeah there's like
this they're saying it and uh yeah
that's what that at this moment in time
that's all we know about what's happened
to our bags i think it's still in
heathrow um if i'm gonna guess
yeah uh hopefully we can hopefully get
our equipment back well like what
happens if they're like oh by the way we
delivered it to lax like a month later
and i'm like we're not in there yeah
i don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
yeah yeah it's just frustrating it's
like i wish they would tell you anything
yeah i think it's the fact that they
don't they like
like the airline leaves you completely
in the dark and doesn't tell you hey
it's here it hasn't been shipped out yet
because it's all backed up yeah okay
well i could somewhat understand that
but when they just [ __ ] tell you
nothing yeah they're like oh no it's an
alias yeah and like like they because
melee was calling them up and being very
angry yeah good good feeling
good mailing uh
they told marlene that like hey yeah the
bags have been at lax since june 16th
yeah yeah and then he goes to lax again
to try and get there and so i [ __ ] so
they told us that the bags had been
delivered to lax so i was just like i
want to go there physically to pick them
up yeah right because we've got 50 000
of equipment i don't want to risk like
wasting any more time so i drive to lax
and of course driving to lax is a
[ __ ] nightmare in la because you have
to like [ __ ] have to drive in l.a
yeah yeah yeah so it takes us about 40
minutes to get to lax and then i go to
the section where they told me to pick
the bags up yeah and i had my second
experience with uh lax customer service
right which was uh i
i uh tried to explain that i have
tickets to pick up my bags um and so the
woman in charge just goes no no no we
don't have any bags from air lingus
right now and that's all she says and
then she goes away she doesn't even give
me time to like explain my situation she
just she just [ __ ] off and i'm like uh
what could i do
what do i do so like i phoned i found
out male 1 to be like can i get like the
exact details of everything our airline
said to you so i can explain the
situation and so this lady goes off and
i can see her in eyesight she goes off
to the other side of the room and starts
like picking up and messing around with
some bags and so i talked to like one of
the security guards there to be like uh
can i call that lady over please because
i think she's in charge of like the
baggage system here and she literally
like picks out her phone and phones the
lady i can see the lady pick up her
phone and answer it
and she and then and then uh she's like
she's like okay and then hangs up and
then she continues messing around with
the bags i can see her in eyesight i see
her you can literally just run up to her
yeah yeah yeah and so after 20 minutes
of [ __ ] around over there i don't
know what she's doing she reluctantly
comes back looks at me and i can see
like the disappointment in her face be
like why the [ __ ] are you calling me
again right and so i'm like trying to
explain
um yeah i just wanted to get more
information and explain more of the
situation about what i've been told and
what the situation is so i explain
everything that melin has explained to
me i give her the tickets and she does a
[ __ ] eye roll and just
like she literally does that and i'm
like why am i being made to feel guilty
yeah for trying to solve a situation
with my bad guys creating yeah yeah yeah
it's just
it made it made like a stressful
situation like eve like 10 times more
stressful because like you know i don't
you know with customer service i don't
mind like if you are not like [ __ ]
japanese level you know
yes king we'll do anything we want for
you you know what do you need i'll
explain everything but
at least don't make the customer feel
guilty about bringing up needing a
service about needing a service it just
it just made me like she made me feel
guilty for even like trying to explain
the situation and trying to find out
more information
um after driving there for 40 minutes
and she goes in she checks the details
on the [ __ ] luggage tag and
everything and then she comes back and
she's just like there is no bags here
your bags and have not been delivered i
don't know what the airline have told
you they've pretty much just said uh
they've pretty much just said something
false because we've had no bags from
that airline at all
and that like that like almost broke me
because that like almost broke me right
because after driving there for 40
minutes not getting my bags after being
delayed for fight like after wasting
five hours of my time the day before
yeah i i now had to drive back from lax
to our studio and
like for some reason god just hated me
on that day because the traffic back was
like way worse than the traffic there so
it took twice the amount of time to
drive back and it was just
ah like i couldn't get adopted oh man
like that like that drove my monk
experience to its limit because i was
like i was like up to here i was about
to [ __ ] explode i'm surprised you
didn't explode i think anyone else would
have [ __ ] exploded long before that
yeah i was like i would have certainly
exploded internally i was screaming
because like i'd like i don't want to
scream at like you know i don't want to
be like the karen to like the customer
service manager but like i just they
just situations like that where i think
it's almost a necessity to be a
character well no because like right
like i didn't want to make i didn't want
to like
like bring out my frustration on the
person right but also that person was i
i felt bringing out her frustrations on
me my customer with maybe previous
customers she's had and i'm just like it
just it just it was just awful
it was an awful experience there's no
there's no there's no silver lining in
this it was just an awful experience and
it's still not resolved um yeah yeah so
it's it wasn't the best first experience
uh touching touching down in america but
uh
yeah welcome to america right